[music]
busy mom Jessica be stunned in the
premere of her New TV Show the sinner
now Jessica plays a murderer Bill pman
is the Detective on the case but last
night Jessica was the one snooping
around as Bill talk to et onl
sop hell  hell I'm going to be doing the
investigative reporting tonight Jessica
had fun crashing our interview but as
executive producer and star of her new
USA Network
jess
ander jess are Real softy and ones Real
hard ass that not really but it sounds
good I think there  wrong with her new
psychological thriller the premieres
tomorrow She's a Young mom who commits a
brutal murder definitely a Dark turn but
h Justin Timberlake couldn't be prouder
tweeting his support But is he scared of
her now I don't think he was scared but
I think I think it was
definitely weird for him to see me like
like that um and I hope that means that
we We're doing a good job and We're
making it look really realistic so
That's thumbs up I Guess If he scared
Tell  me about coming home at the end of
the night to your family your husband
and and your baby and kind of shutting down
that mindset off you don't have a
choice It's called get in the car I
don't bring it home I mean Yes I  'm
exhausted and Sometimes I need like a
glass of wine and just hang out But you
got to let it go you have a two-year Who
just wants to play with you and That's
What most
important [music]